der Kampf der Klimate Chaoten geht in
die nächste Runde im Visier haben Sie
nun die Politik genauer gesagt die
Parteizentralen der ampelregierung doch
auch hierbei trifft es mal wieder
Unschuldige Passanten
[Musik]
jetzt hat es auch die Ampelkoalition
erwischt
farbattacken auf die Parteizentralen von
SPD grün und FDP die klimakaoten der
sogenannten letzten Generation haben
wieder zugeschlagen
eine der regierenden Parteien hat ein
funktionierenden Plan um die
Klimakollaps aufzuhalten der Widerstand
fängt jetzt erst ab
Schmierereien so weit das Auge reicht
und das Festkleben darf natürlich auch
nicht fehlen die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung wird sich über den
Ortswechsel freuen die klimaradikalen
kleben sich nun nicht mehr auf
Straßenfest sondern direkt bei den
zuständigen Parteizentralen der
Regierung doch Unbeteiligte treffen die
klimakaoten selbst hier eine Passanten
wird vor der Grünen zentrale
unfreiwillig mit Farbe beschmiert ich
bin einfach nur wütend war total wenn
sie
wütend ist dass wir sie gerade getroffen
haben das war nicht unsere Absicht bei
den Klima radikalen sind auch inzwischen
bekannte Gesichter dabei einer der
farbschmierer ist Benjamin er war schon
beim Kartoffelbrei Attentat auf das
Monet gemählte im barberini-museum mit
dabei
was sagt es über Deutschland aus das
Wissenschaftler in sich rein Weise dazu
entscheiden Gesetze zu brechen weil die
Erkenntnis dass er dass die Klimakrise
unser Leben bedroht einfach ignoriert
wird
und Klartext zu reden die Regierung hat
es nicht im Griff keine der regierenden
Parteien hat ein funktionierenden Plan
um die Klimakollaps aufzuhalten die
Polizei ermittelt jetzt wegen
Sachbeschädigung und Vandalismus das
Chaos der klimaschmira geht also in die
nächste Runde wenigstens die Autofahrer
konnten dieses Mal aufatmen
ausnahmsweise mal kein Stau
[Musik]